früher englischunterricht bringt nichts
das ist das ergebnis einer neuen studie
demnach haben schülerinnen und schüler
die schon früh begonnen haben englisch
zu lernen keinerlei vorteile gegenüber
schülerinnen und schülern die erst
später mit englisch angefangen haben und
noch schlimmer die schülerinnen und
schüler mit einem späteren lernen waren
sogar besser als die frühstarter über
die ursachen und warum namen nicht immer
etwas bringt jetzt mehr entwicklung
seien 17 herzlich willkommen
das ist echt seltsam wie kann es sein
dass wenn man mehr lernt oder früher
beginnt schlechter ist als menschen die
später damit begonnen haben
zitat der fremdsprachliche frühen beginn
des häufig hoch gelobt obwohl es
insgesamt wenig forschung gibt die
diesen mythos unterstützt das sagt
jäckel vom lehrstuhl didaktik des
englischen an der ruhr universität
bochum
moment da wird etwas praktiziert ohne
das ist ausreichend forschung dazu gibt
echt eltern und kinder was für eine
seltsame beziehung ich habe gerade die
zeit titelgeschichte gelesen das
geschäft mit der elternliebe wahnsinn
deutsche eltern geben jedes jahr 6,5
milliarden euro für kinderausstattung
aus 2009 76 euro kostet die
erstausstattung eines babys im schnitt
es scheint als wollten die eltern die
mangelnde zeit die sie mit ihren kindern
verbringen mit geld und engagement an
der falschen stelle wieder kompensieren
ich sage nur im verweigerung oder eben
jetzt frühförderung das heißt nicht dass
sie generell falsch ist aber sie wird
offensichtlich vollkommen falls und vor
allem unkoordiniert praktiziert kommen
wir also zur untersuchung
die forscherinnen und forscher der
ruhr-universität bochum haben zusammen
mit kolleginnen der technischen
universität dortmund ii daten von 5130
schülerinnen und schülern an gymnasien
in nordrhein-westfalen analysiert in der
fünften klasse war noch alles in ordnung
die früh geförderten schülerinnen und
schüler schnitten allesamt besser ab als
diejenigen die erst in der fünften
klasse mit dem englisch lernen begonnen
hatten check super prima alles klar
forschung beendet zur förderung ist toll
weiter so dass die mars den beiden
universitäten gab sich aber damit nicht
getrieben und worte tiefer wertete also
mehr daten aus und wählt da
dabei kam verblüffendes heraus ab der
siebten klasse schnitten die spätstarter
und spät starterinnen besser ab der
frühe englischunterricht in der
grundschule brachten nicht nur wenig er
war sogar kontraproduktiv
das deckte sich auch mit anderen studien
zum beispiel aus spanien wie auch
herausgefunden hatten dass diese
frühförderung rein gar nichts bringt
aber wie kommt das
die forscherinnen und forscher gehen
davon aus dass eine fremdsprache in
diesem frühen alter nur sehr intensiv
gelernt werden kann zum beispiel als
zweite muttersprache weiterhin vermuten
sie danken es zu einem bruch zwischen
dem spielerischen lernen in der
grundschule und dem sehr strukturierten
lernen im gymnasium kommt da verlieren
die fünf starter und früh starterin den
anschluss weil sie nicht mit der
änderung der methodik zurechtkommen was
ich hier auf jeden fall mal wieder zeit
mit nicht experimentieren wir lieber um
als mit unseren kindern da wird etwas so
unüberlegt praktiziert dass es dann auch
noch die situation der kinder
verschlechtert obwohl es eigentlich gut
gemeint ist das gegenteil von gut ist
eben gut gemeint auf jeden fall muss ihr
unbedingt genauer hingesehen werden und
dieser frühe fremdsprachen unterricht
zumindest so umstrukturiert werden dass
das ganze nicht für die katz ist oder
noch schlimmer nach hinten losgeht die
forscherinnen und forscher schlagen vor
die stundenzahl langsam zu steigern so
dass es zu einem weichen übergang in der
versprühte lernen der fremdsprache kommt
ich lerne übrigen fremdsprachen mit dual
ingo mit der app geht das wirklich super
schnell und superleicht einen link zur
kostenlosen app findet ihr hier
probiert es mal aus und hier geht es zu
einem weiteren lern thema die fünf
besten methoden zum lernen um ihn drauf
klicken und wenn er mir hier ein abo
aufs auge drücken verpackte solche
videos nie mehr vergessen aber nicht den
auf die glocke wird dann bleibt dran